we've always said that if an elder a
senior
um is in line we're going to move them
to the front of the line barring that
anyone that signs up over the age of 16
whether you live in alaska and if you
plan on working in alaska
you can get a vaccination and so we're
encouraging as many folks as possible to
do this
we believe neil that we're going to be
achieving herd immunity probably before
any other state here shortly
all right it's physically by far the
biggest state in the country now alaska
stands out for
uh having the most open vaccine policy
of any other state in the country you
can be as young as 16
and they're ready to boogie when it
comes to giving you the vaccine
uh mike dunleavy says that's the only
way to do things and he raised a good
point with me that in that state where
some towns and villages have spread by
hundreds
of miles coming back and forth and
arranging wait times with people who
who just want to get that vaccine seemed
a little bit silly mike parson
the governor of missouri is dealing with
these issues at vaccines and getting
everyone what they need when they need
it he was kind enough to join us here
uh on a saturday from springfield
governor very good to see you again how
you doing
i'm doing good neil good to see you this
morning
same here so let's talk a little bit
about what your vaccine kind of rules
are uh who gets to the front of the line
how big is that line
what are you doing yeah you know the
main priority we've had is the
same plan we sent in october to the cdc
and we were absolutely executing that
plan just like it was originally
put together and making sure we're not
doing any jerk reactions to
everybody wanting to jump the line our
biggest priority is people 65 years and
old the most vulnerable population in
our state
and we stayed focused on that next week
we'll go to teachers we'll go to utility
workers we'll go to the next level
but that's frankly several weeks ahead
of it and right now we're second in the
united states with the lowest positivity
rate in the country
and when you have that going because of
things we've done and we never shut our
state down we never shut it down for the
state of missouri
we never did the mandates from the
governor's office so i think a
combination of staying with the vaccine
plan
and making sure we get that done and
having the national guard i can't say
enough for their support
doing mass vaccine operations and we
will be doing a mega vaccine
operation next week in kansas city
missouri so
there's not enough vaccine we understand
that everybody does but i mean it's all
hands on deck right now and we're
putting needles in people's arms that
want it
you know governor the president has
outlined a goal of getting every
american adult who wants to be
vaccinated
uh vaccinated by day first doable in
your eyes
you know i think you'll get close to
that i don't know that you're going to
get it all done by may the first i think
that's a prediction you know maybe it's
wishful thinking but i
you know it's going to take us a while
to get everybody vaccinated i think the
main thing is you get the high risk
categories done i do believe we can get
that done
by the first part of may and then i
think you're going to see
in the next 60 days where people maybe
can just go to the pharmacy can go the
healthcare clinics
and probably more get vaccines on their
own than happen to depend
on actually state governments to run
those plans
governor what is your policy on masks
i'm sorry neil what was that i'm sorry
what's your policy on masks governor
well you know the next thing the next
thing we're going to be doing
uh as we move forward is to go to
some of the mega vaccines and then also
we'll take that next stage of people
that comes in and then we'll get in what
we call
phase three and phase three will get
pretty close to the entire general
public that's out there so
again we're about two weeks ahead of
everything we've predicted so far at
this point
so we just keep moving that to the next
level
governor thank you very much very little
fanfare um you've just been
very diligent throughout this process
and it seems to be working mike parson
the governor beautiful state
of missouri we appreciate that sir be
well be safe